all right are we still riding the high
of newlywed Bliss are we still in the
love Bubble yeah
I always gets been the best part of
for you did you say yours just being
together yeah and finding you know
like he's you know he's true love really
true love my soul mate yeah falling
asleep with the person you love and
waking up next to the person you love is
actually an amazing thing it's like
we're probably one of the hardest things
to find in life that consistency and
balance and that's that's what I love I
remember when we moved in I was like
we're moving boxes around I said to you
like it's okay in a few hours we're
gonna spend our first night together you
know that's that's amazing all those
special moments together yeah we just
made one year living together yeah yeah
wow that's something to celebrate yeah
um Blended families another kids kill
each other you know they were older
people survived another season of
filming Housewives yeah is it tough you
know so much has come out Whispers of
what happens is it tough to have to wait
so long for the viewers to actually see
what unfolded does that make you kind of
like Ugh I wish they just knew we
unfortunately have to relive it again
yeah but I'm looking forward to my
wedding so that I can't wait to relive
because that that was such a beautiful
amazing moment and I can't wait for
everyone to see it have you seen in the
Bravo land Bazaar they've got your dress
and your crown there and then you can
pose as if you are you
yeah they like
like look at my story and then they put
his face in my dress it was so cute
where do you and your brother stand have
you been able to connect since
everything went down or is it still kind
of your keeping distance for now yeah
yeah I need time to heal
what are you what is your hope for that
relationship
I you know whatever whatever God says
yeah yesterday he told me whatever
Teresa wants whatever Teresa says goes
from here on out oh I love that
last night uh you
you from your seat yeah why did you feel
the need to do that because everyone was
coming up to me they're like you know
Vicky through your shade and I'm like
why you know like that was really like
for this is my whole thing we're
Housewives and we should all be lifting
each other up like nobody should be like
saying anything negative about anyone
else I don't know what did you think of
Melissa's performance that closed out
the show amazing that's very nice they
were everyone's amazing listen we're all
talented we're all obviously on this
platform for a reason all right before I
let you go what is one word you can
leave me with to tease me with for the
season we're about to watch
truth truth he nailed it
[Music]